hi-hi-hi that movie was terrifying I had
nightmares yeah truly I truly had
nightmares a fantastic job you really
you really keep that character grounded
what was your approach in making this
because I know the original 40 years ago
you know maybe the expectations were
different in making it but how did your
approach change this time yes the there
were no expectations and making it we
were lucky to pull together 20 days of
shooting you know I wanted to make sure
that she was a wounded warrior I didn't
want her to be some sort of cartoon
tough girl I wanted to be able to show
the trauma enough that you understood
her pain without it being something that
made the movie sour and too heavy and I
think that's really David's great gift
as the director was that he feathered in
just enough of the grief and the trauma
that she's carried for 40 years and then
absolutely gave her full throttle to to
kick into a different gear mmm
were you surprised that this would be a
direct sequel from classic 40 years ago
yeah I wasn't surprised I was wildly
pleased that that was the the thought
because you know there been a few other
Halloween movies and they all have some
legitimacy and if you people have a
certain one that they like great there's
something very powerful about a movie 40
years ago and a sequel 40 years later
with the same woman playing that part
and exploring generational trauma the
way this movie does yeah and you know
what your character and also to Linda
Hamilton in Terminator both kick-ass
characters coming back right now why do
you think that's so important at a time
like this
well I think women are coming back in
many many many areas and ways I think it
is a time for women and Laurie Strode is
a representation of a very intelligent
thoughtful young woman who became a
victim of random acts of violence that
then basically defined her life for 40
years until she takes back the narrative
through her actions what do you do for
Halloween you celebrate Halloween you
know what we're actually pretty quiet we
live on a street that's very quiet
nobody ever shows up no trick-or-treat
we don't have trick-or-treaters I mean
that guy who's walking up the street
okay that's terrifying okay he'd
trick-or-treat he always comes to my
house I paint dong and then he just
stands there and then he looks at me and
then he looks at like the camera my
security cameras and then he does this
tips his head and then I'm like what I
have no candy and then he leaves and
then he comes back every year it's kind
really scary I know it's a little creepy
it's really scary I know welcome to my
life just it's too much your
granddaughter in the movie Andy did you
help her perfect the screen like any
scream queen no you know what there it's
interesting screaming in in a horror
movie mmm I remember exactly where I was
the night we did the scene in 40 years
ago in West Hollywood where Laurie has
now gone across the street has seen what
happened to her friends has now been
stabbed by the shape she has fallen down
the stairs she has broken through the
kitchen window and there is a shot where
there outside the house and she comes
running out she's screaming she falls on
the ground she goes to the house next
door she knocks on the door and then she
exits it I remember we were Hurst it
with the camera the Steadicam we knew
exactly where I was gonna fall and then
I was gonna get up and the camera we
were her stood three or four times at
speed but not screaming because why
would you do that and then I remember
standing behind the house and this was
the first time because at this point you
know already I'd spent a lot of time in
the movie just being Laurie now like the
stuffs happening and I remember standing
behind the house cameras in front of the
house and I remember hearing like the
movie thing like we're rolling while
rolling and then I heard them go speed
marker and then I heard from like a
bullhorn oh and I remember standing
behind this house thinking what do I do
like I remember thinking like wait what
and then doing it and I remember who
does that no acting classes like and and
he had the same thing like she had never
done it we had rehearsed it all and then
there was this moment and it's just
something that happens
terrifying I'm terrified but it's
terrifying because the hope of course is
that no one ever has to really do that
in life sadly of course that's not true
but it's so funny you would bring that
up because I remember literally going
like
what am I supposed to do here and then
when you see that movie again that shot
of lorry running out in the back of that
house was like the first time in
Halloween I had ever screamed and it was
just like that whole sequence thank you
super cool thank you so much